sur public sénat bonjour à tous cet
après midi les sénateurs débattent à
l'initiative du groupe ump de
l'accession au logement ce thème c'est
un des engagements de campagne de
nicolas sarkozy qui a promis de faire de
la france un pays de propriétaires
l'accession à la propriété est difficile
pour des raisons économiques encore
amplifiée par la crise et donc depuis
2007 ce sont tout un ensemble de mesures
qui ont été mises en place afin de
répondre à ce problème avec le prêt à
taux zéro le prêt d'accession sociale ou
bien encore la défiscalisation des
emprunts benoist apparu le secrétaire
d'état au logement a également mis
l'accent sur la vente des logements
sociaux à leurs occupants l'objectif de
ce débat c'est donc d'évaluer
l'efficacité de ces dispositifs
selon jean françois mayet le sénateur
ump à l'origine de ce débat reste encore
de nombreux problèmes à résoudre le
problème de la spéculation immobilière
qui gonflent les prix celui de la
centralisation de la politique de
l'habitat
l'empilement des ados logement ou bien
encore le problème du nombre insuffisant
des logements construits en zone tendue
tout de suite donc direction l'hémicycle
pour ce débat sur l'accession à la
propriété
l'ordre du jour mais maintenant appel
débat sur l'accession à la propriété
la parole est tout d'abord à l'orateur
du groupe qui a demandé ce débat il
s'agit de notre collègue jean françois
mallet pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
j
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président monsieur mini char
collègues avant d'entrer dans le sujet
de l'accession je voudrais dire à vous
monsieur le ministre
mon propos ne constituent pas une charge
à l'égard des mesures que vous nous
proposez à ce sujet ces mesures
ces mesures je les vôtres et parce
qu'elles vont dans le bon sens parce
qu'elles ont dans le bon sens elles sont
d'ailleurs incluse dans le projet de
lequel sur lequel nous travaillons et
que j'ai eu l'occasion de présenter à
vos collaborateurs
elles sont cependant partiel car s'il
essentiellement des classes moyennes et
ne traite pas la globalité du problème à
mon sens pour ma part je suis convaincu
qu'une loi sur l'accession à la
propriété capable de faire bouger les
choses en france doit intégrer les plus
faibles des français car maintenir ces
derniers dans leur statut de locataire
ne leur rapporte rien et coûte
finalement plus cher à la collectivité
je voudrais vous faire partager un
certain nombre de constats qui sont ceux
qui ont justifié notre travail et qui
ont guidé sa réalisation
la france compte 57 % propriétaire c'est
beaucoup moins tous ses voisins et ceux
shield et sera encore si nous faisons
rien en raison simplement de la
croissance démographique et vous l'avez
calculé monsieur 75,14 bon sens des
français trouvent ce chiffre insuffisant
mais 83 % pensent qu'il est difficile
voire impossible de devenir propriétaire
j'emploie par ailleurs des élus
politiques de tous bords exprimé les
mêmes réserves ce qui à mon sens est
encore plus grave
le monde hlm reste extrêmement frileux à
l'égard de l'accession confortablement
installé dans le métier de loueurs
qu'une maîtrise depuis 60 ans le
résultat est que depuis 25 ans toutes
les tentatives de développer l'accession
certes très timides ont échoué et le
constat final est un constat d'échec
ceci est vrai pour le public comme pour
le privé
je dois dire que je suis stupéfait du
silence entretenu par les milieux
politiques et les bailleurs sociaux à ce
sujet exception faite du gouvernement
actuel
c'est certain au delà au-delà des
statistiques qui n'apportent pas elles
seules des solutions essayons de poser
le vrai problème et les vraies questions
pour nous justifier longtemps qu'à grand
nombre de français soit encore locataire
l'âge de la retraite assujettis ainsi à
loyer qui continuera d'augmenter jusqu'à
leur décès c'est la situation devienne
en conséquence de quoi ils n'auront
aucun patrimoine à transmettre ou avant
pour assumer leur éventuelle intégration
dans la maison de retraite de leur choix
je ne le crois pas et je suis convaincu
qu'il existe des solutions qui passent
forcément est d'abord par les bailleurs
sociaux
permettez moi se rappelle les bailleurs
sociaux ont été créés dans les années
1920 et jusqu'à la guerre ils ont permis
à 80% de leurs résidents d'accéder à la
propriété c'était le réseau d'at après
la guerre ils ont dû loger dans
l'urgence et décemment des millions de
français venus de la campagne
vous avez tous connu ça en province puis
des millions d'émigrés venues d'ailleurs
ils l'ont bien fait mais ils ont changé
de métier en devenant exclusivement des
loueurs
ce qui n'était peut être pas leur choix
c'est de là que vient cette spécificité
française qui fait qu avant la dernière
guerre les français les plus modestes
étaient propriétaires et qu'aujourd'hui
ils ne le sont plus c'est avec les
bailleurs sociaux que nous assumerons
cette seconde mutation en engageant leur
puissance de construction leur
savoir-faire de gestionnaire et leur
poids financier oui leur poids financier
c'est à dire leur capacité à
autofinancer et emprunter lorsque cette
mutation en faveur de l'accession sera
engagée le secteur privé suivra il sera
bien obligé car il y en a effectivement
l'obligation commerciales et financières
de le faire sinon d'un d'autres le
feront à sa place les bailleurs sociaux
doivent être les premiers le premier
levier
le levier essentiel d'une nouvelle
politique qui constitue un véritable
ébauche challenge 75 à 80 % de
propriétaires en 2025 sera nécessaire si
nous voulons en faire bénéficier les
plus faibles en dessous en dessous de ce
taux évidemment les plus faibles ils
sont pas vécues car ne pouvons pas nous
contenter des classes moyennes pour cela
nous devons construire dans la même
période
7 millions 500 mille logements privés
publics et privés bien entendu un
parcours résidentiel doit être
systématiquement proposé aux entrant
chez les bailleurs sociaux afin qu'ils
deviennent propriétaires en fin de
parcours
au cours de la même période les anciens
locataires
bien sûr on peut pas laisser pour compte
ils payent un loyer depuis 30 ans 35 ans
devront pouvoir acquérir leur logement
dans le cadre d'un crédit dont les
mensualités de remboursement ne
dépasseront pas le dernier voyez ce
retour au pré lieu qui constitue
évidemment une étable changement résumé
par ces chiffres
80% de construction neuve dédié à la
location accession 20% seulement
réserver l'allocation alors
qu'actuellement et construisent 80 pour
loin 80 % pour louer et 20% pour accéder
et 40 % du patrimoine liste et devraient
être cédés aux anciens locataires d'ici
par ailleurs un métier nouveau doit être
dévolu aux hlm celui d'assurer la
mobilité
monsieur ministre en garantissant le
rachat échange aux locataires
volontaires ou contraints de changer de
résidence ou de ville pour des raisons
familiales ou professionnelles et ceci
sans perdre de crédit acquis dans le
cadre du contrat en cours
le financement des politiques est
évidemment déterminant pour la réussite
et la pérennité de ce projet jusqu'à
maintenant nous avons privilégié la
location en y engageant plus de 45
milliards par an ainsi la globalité de
l'aide à la location notamment l'appel
versé à un couple de locataires
au cours de sa vie peut atteindre et
dépasser 300 mille euros de plus les
défiscalisations loi de robien scellier
etc ont toujours favorisé la location
toujours favoriser la location
il est donc urgent il est donc urgent de
réorienter toutes les aides directes et
indirectes vers les accidents occupants
il faudra aussi que de nouveaux outils
juridiques et financiers voient le jour
et quel état est la volonté d'assainir
les transactions foncières qui souffre
d'une spéculation devenu insupportable
notamment dans les territoires en
tension
ce point demandera beaucoup de courage
politique pour tous et qu'ils tenteront
tout cela aura un coût je ne perds pas
de vue l'obligation plus qu'impérieuse
de réduire les dépenses publiques
cependant le coût du système actuel est
tellement lourde que nous pourrions
avoir de belles surprises
créer et transmettre un patrimoine est
nécessaire à l' équilibre de l'homme
cela est vrai pour toutes les classes
sociales et notamment pour les plus
faibles
quel beau résultat de réunir les
conditions qui permettraient d'abaisser
les priorités en rendant systématique
l'accession à la propriété au travers
d'un contrat de location vente et en
réservant l'appelation à ceux qui le
souhaitent et seulement à cela pour
conclure permettez moi d'affirmer que ce
dispositif des chiffres destinés à
chaque citoyen ou couple de citoyens
mais de chance d'exister de fonctionner
que celui donnant la force d'une loi
c'est la raison pour laquelle je ferai
une proposition dans ce sens qui
j'espère reculera l'approbation du plus
grand nombre et je ne souhaite pas que
ça devienne la loi maillé gallopin tu
vois là je voudrais vous dire pour
compléter que ce projet sur lequel nous
travaillons piano c'est le projet de
plusieurs bailleurs sociaux dont 1 je
connais bien qui est indigne à est prête
à servir d'expérimentation dans ma ville
de châteauroux et dans le département de
l'âme jour merci merci
mon cher collègue dans la suite du débat
la parole est maintenant monsieur
thierry repentin pour le groupe
socialiste
vous avez la parole de leurs collègues
pour lui minutes
ce président est monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
l'orateur précédent a beaucoup parlé
d'une l'accession à la propriété je
regrette que son initiative est aussi
peu d'écho est ce une question qui
intéresse le groupe qui était à
l'origine de cette inscription à l'ordre
du jour on peut se poser la question
quand on voit le peu d'acidité sur ce
sujet monsieur le ministre
l'historien du logement roger henri
gerrans qui est malheureusement nous a
quitté en 2006 avait coutume de dire
quand on devient propriétaire on devient
conservateur faut-il chercher là les
raisons d'un engouement pour l'accession
à la propriété et c'est vrai que l'on
voit qu'on devient conservateur quand on
devient propriétaire tous les élus
locaux le service i c'est difficile de
faire construire un logement neuf à côté
d'une maison de quelqu'un qui vient de
s'installer on est donc effectivement
conservateur le désert de l'hémicycle va
me faire abréger mes propos monsieur le
ministre
parce que vous parlez beaucoup avec
insistance d'un nouveau projet de
société d'un impératif nouveau de
modèles économiques notamment sur
l'accession à la propriété
alors je suis allé voir la liste des
pays membres vertueux de l'union
européenne ce qui compte le plus de
propriétaires dans leurs pays la
roumanie 96% la lituanie et la slovaquie
89% la hongrie 87% et l'espagne qui n'en
finit pas de plonger dans la crise avec
83% l'espagne qui vient d'adopter un
dispositif pour faire que par exemple
sur les grandes villes il y ait 50 % de
logements sociaux locatifs nouveau dans
toute construction
c'est à dire deux fois plus que
l'article 55 de la loi sru les autres
pays qui seraient moins vertueux dans
l'union européenne l'allemagne
l'autriche le danemark les pays bas qui
ont tous des taux de propriétaires
inférieur ou équivalent la france et je
ne parle pas de la suisse qui
coût plus de logements locatifs que de
propriétaires mais c'est vrai que c'est
pour accueillir notamment un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens qui cherche à
trouver un domicile fiscal
le centre d'analysé stratégique monsieur
le ministre qui est un organe rattaché
aux services du premier ministre publie
le mois dernier une étude très
intéressante indiquant un lien fort
entre statut d'occupation du logement
mobilité marché du travail
le casse soulignant que je cite les pays
ayant les plus forts taux de
propriétaires occupants sont aussi ceux
qui connaissent les taux de chômage les
plus élevés continuent en disant si l'on
comparé des individus de même profil
socio-professionnel en france un
propriétaire occupant met plus de temps
à retrouver un travail qu'un locataire
sa durée de chômage est d'environ 30%
supérieur entraînant une plus forte
proportion de chômeurs que chez les
locataires de même catégorie
socioprofessionnelle si je le dit sam ce
ministre
c'est pourquoi on érige pas une idée en
dogme le tout propriétaire
le tout propriétaire ne peut pas être un
modèle de société pour autant pour nous
la propriété c'est une réponse possible
à ceux qui en expriment le souhait et
qui tiennent compte des comptes des
contributions possibles de nos
concitoyens en effet l'accession à la
propriété c'est un des éléments
fondamentaux de la politique du logement
de notre pays pour les ménages qui
peuvent acquérir un logement dans des
conditions satisfaisantes
c'est un facteur de sécurisation
notamment dans la perspective de la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat au moment des
retraites tout autre sujet important
or l'accession marque le pas c'est un
fait
du fait des difficultés économiques des
ménages et du niveau des prix les
ménages les plus modestes
ça intéressera notre collègue sont de
moins en moins fréquemment propriétaires
de leur logement à linverse des ménages
les plus aisés en 84 dans le car l'apd
le plus modeste de la population 47 %
des ménages étaient propriétaires 60%
dans le quart le plus aisé en 84 en 2006
la portion la proportion chez les plus
modestes tombe à 39%
elle s'envole
76 % dans les plus aisés et par ailleurs
les jeunes ménages qui sont incités
accéder tôt pour tenir compte de
l'allongement de la durée de
l'endettement sont également en
difficulté pour le faire tant du fait de
loyers du marché élevée peu favorable à
la constitution d'une épargne préalable
que de la précarité de leurs ressources
l'option mise d'aller faire des
économies grâce à la suppression des
dispositions que nous avions combattu à
l'époque de la loi tepa car nous avions
dit qu'elle ne produirait pas un
propriétaire de plus en france et
qu'elle coûterait cher à notre budget
avec cet argent économisé sur le budget
je pense que l'on peut valoriser donné
un pouvoir sur solvabilisateur
supplémentaire au prêt à taux zéro
prioritairement pour les ménages aux
revenus modestes ou moyens première
piste deuxième piste sûr vous allez me
répondre sur la première positivement
vous allez nous faire une démonstration
et la deuxième c'est l'instauration d'un
champ tva à 5,5 pour l'accession à la
propriété pour les ménages modestes
vous avez l'argent pour le faire
monsieur le ministre car la suppression
du pass foncier et de l'impôt du crédit
d'impôt de tva supprimer vont vous faire
économiser 4 milliards 500 millions
d'euros alors que la modification du ptz
tel que vous le prenez vous fera dépensé
3 milliards donc il ya un milliard 500
millions d'économies qui ne sont pas
utilisés ce qui veut dire qu'après
réforme
il n'ya pas maintien de la dépense
globale de l'état pour l'accession mais
sa diminution nette
une partie importante de l'économie
faite sur le crédit d'impôt tepa est en
rapporter au budget de l'état
je précise également que l'élargissement
de dernier décile vous fera dépensé 400
millions d'euros alors même qu avant la
réforme
80% des ménages qui sont dans ces 20 %
les plus aisés sont d'ores et déjà
propriétaire et que du coup le prêt à
taux zéro ne leur sert pas et que
l'élargissement à ces deux derniers
disent il va vous faire dépenser de
l'argent inutilement
pourquoi cette priorité sur les ménages
modestes et moyens se
nous premièrement les coûts des emprunts
selon les statistiques de la banque de
france
on peut estimer la durée d'emprunt
immobiliers passés de 14 années en 96 à
19 en 2010 ça veut dire qu on s'endette
sur une période beaucoup plus longue
pour être propriétaire
deuxièmement la hausse des prix depuis
96 les prix immobiliers ont été
multipliés par deux et demi aucun revenu
n'a suivi évidemment cette évolution
pour voir son projet aboutir un candidat
à l'accession a dû ajuster son projet en
achetant un produit de qualité moins
élevés ou plus éloignés de son lieu
d'emploi en augmentant son apport
personnel ou en achetant plus petit
qu'il ne le réveille et par ailleurs les
prix du foncier sur cette même période
ont été multipliées par sept nuits alors
monsieur le ministre c'est lorsque les
sociétés sécurisé le moins les parcours
de vie des personnes que le désir
d'accession à la propriété et le plus
fort c'est en quelque sorte un palliatif
individuel lorsque les garanties
collectives c'est-à-dire en fait un
modèle de société ne permettent plus
d'envisager sereinement ses vieux jours
monsieur le ministre il faut donc
changer de braquet et pour changer de
braquet il faut agir sur les prix
notre effort sur la solvabilisation ne
doit pas faiblir
mais en l'état du marché ne sera jamais
suffisant à compenser l'inflation
immobilière et foncière exponentielle de
ces dernières années je vous pose donc
des questions très précises
comment allez-vous réguler le prix des
terrains taxes et la rétention foncière
plafonner les loyers séparer le marché
de la primo-accession de celui
l'accession secondaire
messieurs le ministre sur ces sujets
essentiels quelles sont vos propositions
pour que votre ambition ne produisent
pas le même manque de réalisations que
l'ambition de votre prédécesseur avec la
célèbre maison à 100000 euros
merci monsieur collègue monsieur parent
les mettre dans notre collègue jean
pierre plancade pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique social
européen
la parole mon cher collègue monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues une france de propriétaires
c'est ce que déjà valéry giscard
d'estaing en 1974 avait annoncé et qui a
été repris par l'actuel président de la
république
certes il répond sans doute à
l'inspiration de nombreux français la
possession d'un logement est en effet
une réponse aux craintes sur l'avenir
des retraites
ainsi qu un besoin légitime de
transmission et de solidarité
intergénérationnelle et plus
particulièrement le goût des français
pour l'habitat individuel
il s'agit là de mon point de vue bien
sûr d'un vieux mythe conservateur
réactionnaire
faisant fi des réalités qu implique
qu'on pratique une telle politique et je
parle essentiellement dans nos
agglomérations la maison individuelle
dans une agglomération c'est l'étalement
urbain avec toutes les dépenses que cela
occasionne pour une collectivité
publique mais aussi pour les ménages
mais fait aggravant cela a favorisé la
spéculation immobilière
ce qui a eu pour conséquence évidemment
de renchérir le coût des terrains et par
delà celui de l'accession à la propriété
quant à l'accession sociale à la
propriété de type logement aux
appartements sans accompagnement
la conséquence est souvent ce qu'il est
convenu d'appeler aujourd'hui de
constater d'ailleurs les copropriétés
dégradées et pourtant monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues que je
continue à penser qu'il faut encourager
et favoriser un parcours résidentiel 10
à 100 dans tout cela pour dire tout cela
pour dire que si l'on veut favoriser
l'accession à la propriété il faut
d'abord une mesure simple maîtriser le
foncier et cela passe parce qu'on l'a
beaucoup publié depuis dix ans par la
réactivation des zones d'aménagement
différé qui ont le mérite de geler le
prix du terrain cela passe par
l'appropriation par les collectivités le
terrain constructible le plus tôt
possible
cela passe également par une taxation
conséquence conséquente et obligatoire
des terrains qui sont rendus
constructibles à la suite d'une décision
publique
soyons lucides l'accession à la
propriété est devenu de moins en moins
accessibles aux ménages à revenus
ça vient d'être dit tandis que la
proportion des ménages sous plafond pl
us grimpé de 64 à 74 % entre 2000 et
2006 la proportion des ménages à moins
de 3 me parmi les accédants chuté de 45
à 33 % les classes moyennes ont elles
aussi subi fortement la crise et la
pression immobilière
il faut dire qu'en 15 ans les prix de
l'immobilier ont été multiplié par deux
et demi alors que le revenu des ménages
n'a progressé que d'un point et demi
malgré la victime la déductibilité des
intérêts d'emprunt les prêts à taux zéro
le pass foncier les maisons à 100 mille
euros c'est la 15 euros par jour et le
taux d'intérêt très bas la france des
propriétaires n'a pas beaucoup progressé
57 % de propriétaires se siffler je
siffle on n'a pas bougé depuis 2007 et
je passe sur ce qu'a dit mon
prédécesseur vous nous avez proposé une
réforme des aides à l'accession une de
plus si je peux me permettre ainsi le
ptz prêt à taux zéro plus d'en vau l'eau
dit qu'il mobilisera deux milliards 600
millions d'euros au lieu d'un milliard
de mai vous prévoyez de supprimer
d'autres financements comme le passeront
aussi le crédit foncier
le crédit d'impôt sur les intérêts
d'emprunt et d'autres encore
bref globalement j'ai calculé que l'aide
à la pierre à les diminuer de 50%
mais cette nouvelle mesure n'est pas
soumise à conditions de ressources ce
qui devrait pas favoriser les plus
pauvres est centrée sur les zones les
plus tendues
doit-on s'en réjouir ou et non oui pour
les zones qui manquent de logements mais
non car 30% des ménages mais seulement
30% vivre dans des zones dans
l'agglomération de moins de 5000
habitants
enfin je suis un de ceux qui pensent
qu'il faut que les offices hlm met à la
vente une partie de leur patrimoine
je rappelle que la somme dégagée par la
vente d'un appartement permet d'en
construire trois ou quatre mais
aujourd'hui les offices hlm sont arc
boutés sur un positionnement qui de mon
point de vue est un positionnement
idéologique parce que on pourrait
entendre que la vente d'appartements
public serait en quelque sorte une
privatisation rampante d'un bien public
je rappelle qu'il s'agirait seulement de
vendre à un particulier et je dis bien
particuliers de vendre et la vente
devrait se faire sous garantie en cas
d'accident de la vie
et que le syndic de la copropriété
demeurerait l'office hlm vendeur mais le
proverbe dit quand on veut tuer son
chien on dit qu'il a la rage
hélas les autistes hln excellent les
gens ne seraient pas acquéreur au motif
qu'ils ne voudraient pas acheter un
logement dégradé dans une zone dégradé
évidemment si on veut en vendre des
appartements dégradé personne n'en
voudra mais dans les propriétés hlm
il n'y a pas que des appartements
dégradée dans des immeubles dégradés et
dans des zones dégradées
j'en connais j'y ai même vécu en réalité
on voit aujourd'hui que le problème -
l'accession à la propriété que l'axé
tout court en logements les causes sont
diverses précarisation des ménages
loyers de plus en plus déconnectés des
revenus insuffisance de construction de
logements enfin bref on connaît ça par
coeur ici le déficit serait de 900 mille
logements dont cinq à six cents mille
sociaux et mais j'avoue que je demeure
perplexe quand on sait que la trésorerie
du monde hlm est de l'ordre de 7
milliards d'euros
et quand on dit cela on trouve toujours
un savant plus avant que l'autre qui
vous dit oui c'est vrai mais c'est pas
comme cela est la réalité beaucoup plus
complexe et que tout cela ne sont que de
mauvais prétextes de mon point de vue
d'ailleurs le lobby d'union des hlm est
tellement puissant qu'il touche à la
fois la droite et la gauche
on l'a vu ici la semaine dernière j'en
parlerai vous monsieur mise je sais pas
trop comment d'ailleurs on a supprimé un
amendement bref on aura l'occasion
sûrement à l'occasion de la défiance
d'en reparler moi je voudrais rappeler
une chose et c'est dramatique d'être
obligé de le rappeler ici que les
offices hlm sont un outil au service des
collectivités locales pour rénover et
produire du logement et non pour faire
d'après the rye ou se livrer comme
certains à des opérations financières
douteuses
je sais que ce n'est pas la majorité
mais c'est une réalité et je dois le
dire aujourd'hui ils sont parfaitement
relayé par ce qui est devenu ce que
j'appelle un syndicat professionnel et
corporatistes qui est l'union des hlm
vraiment je crois que c'est ce qui a qui
a généré une techno bureaucratie qui
finit par vivre pour elle même en
perdant de vue ce pourquoi elle existe
et ce pour quoi elle est née et tous ces
gens là largement diplômés d'ailleurs au
lieu de mettre leur savoir au service de
l'innovation au service de la créative
et de trouver des formules intelligente
qui aide les collectivités locales à
produire moins cher
il emploie toute cette énergie en la
défense des 3 0 et des offices hlm
c'est une perte de sens total monsieur
le ministre d'ailleurs dès lors que l'on
créé une union pour quelque chose c'est
en général pour affirmer la défense
d'intérêts particuliers liés à la
profession par sont là dessus alors
certes il y à la crise économique
certes il y a le désengagement de l'état
mais ces deux facteurs ne doivent pas
enlever un troisième qui est majeure
c'est celui de la volonté politique
locale qui ne relèvent ni de l'état ni
de la crise et qu'on ne peut pas enlever
aux maires aux présidents d'agglo aux
offices au président de l'office des hlm
or force est de constater que cette
volonté politique sur tous les bancs et
at home est atone sinon il ya longtemps
que nous aurions résolu le problème de
logement dans ce pays est d'ailleurs moi
qui suis un décentralisateur par essence
je pense aujourd'hui que cette politique
trop et trop décentralisée elle est un
frein au développement de l'ordre parce
que nos élus sont fragilisés par des
populations qui prenant de l'âge repliée
sur elle-même ne veulent plus voir dans
leur ville
arrivée des populations nouvelles dites
pauvres et nos élus locaux résistent mal
peu voire pas du tout à cette pression
enfin je voudrais dire qu'on entretient
une autre confusion grave dans nos
agglomérations
ce n'est pas mesdames et messieurs mes
chers collègues larchitecture ce n'est
pas la concentration urbaine qui crée le
malaise c'est le chômage c'est la crise
économique qui s'enrhume responsable de
ce malaise social et pas autre chose
alors monsieur le ministre je vous le
dis je le redis certes je pense qu'on
peut pas non plus prétendre bâtir une
politique d'accession à la propriété
quand on dit diminue de moitié les et la
pierre la question que je voudrais vous
poser
ne pensez vous pas qu'il est grand temps
que l'état reprenne les choses en main
précisément parfois pour enlever
quelques contraintes à des à des élus
locaux qui pensent comme vous mais qui
n'osent pas le dire si mon cher collègue
la parole est à notre collègue madame
odette terrade pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen sénateurs du parti
de gauche n'avait la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues les sénateurs membres du
groupe de la majorité parlementaire ont
fait le choix dans l'ordre du jour
réservé de mettre en débat la question
de l'accession à la propriété
il est vrai que le président de la
république avait fait d'une france de
propriétaires
un leitmotiv de sa campagne
présidentielle mais force est de
constater que quelques années plus tard
les résultats n'ont pas été ceux
escomptés
il est vrai que selon l'adage les
promesses n'engagent que ceux qui les
croient sans y voir de malice nous
estimons que ce débat sur l'accès à la
propriété donne l'impression d'être
utilisé par la majorité comme un
artifice visant à détourner l'attention
de la véritable urgence
c'est à dire le mal logement qui touche
plus de 3 5 millions de personnes dans
notre pays
mal-logement exacerbée par l'absence
concrète d'un droit au logement
opposable de manière plus cynique encore
on peut y voir un lien avec l'actuel
débat sur les retraites
vous avez jugé utile et nécessaire
monsieur le ministre de proclamer que
posséder son logement c'est la
constitution d'un capital pour la
retraite
cela s'apparente à une forme d'aveu sur
la baisse évidente des pensions que va
générer la réforme en cours et donc sur
sa nocivité social nocivité sociale qui
donne raison à ces millions de gens qui
manifestent mais qu'elle n'est pas notre
sujet aujourd'hui en se faisant
cependant l'apôtre d'une france de
propriétaires en consacrant pour ce
faire des dispositifs fiscaux avantageux
sans aucune prise en compte de la
problématique sociale
le président de la république a pourtant
commis un manquement grave
il faut d'ailleurs se souvenir qu'avant
la crise des subprimes il ne tarissait
pas d'éloges sur les crédits
hypothécaires
c'est dire la pertinence qui
caractérisait son jugement sur les
solutions à mettre en oeuvre pour
répondre à la crise du logement que
connaît notre pays
pourtant la crise des sub prime a
largement démontré que vouloir ainsi à
tout prix favoriser l'accession à la
propriété indépendamment de la question
du pouvoir d'achat ne pouvait produire
que des catastrophes humaines poussant
les gens à s'endetter sur plusieurs
générations
pour le plus grand bonheur des banques
c'est d'ailleurs ce mécanisme qui
conduit aujourd'hui à ce qu'il y ait 778
1000 personnes en procédure de
surendettement
pas étonnant dans ces conditions comme
l'a rappelé notre collègue tout à
l'heure que 83 % de nos concitoyens
pensent impossible de devenir
propriétaire en effet comment parler
d'accession à la propriété en dehors de
toute considération humaine ainsi pour
devenir propriétaire aujourd'hui non
seulement il faut pouvoir disposer de
ressources suffisantes mais également
pouvoir témoigner d'une certaine
stabilité dans son parcours
professionnel
or les préceptes libéraux et la
politique menée par ce gouvernement
conduisent la plupart de nos concitoyens
à la précarité et à l'instabilité
notamment par une mobilité
professionnelle accrue je rappelle ici
les propos de madame parisot présidente
du medef qui s'interrogeait en ces
termes si la vie la santé l'amour sont
précaires pourquoi le travail
échapperait il à cette loi mais
peut-être at-il échappé à la patronne
des patrons qu'il est justement demandé
aux accédants à la propriété de
justifier d'un travail et d'un revenu
non précaires pour pouvoir prétendre
obtenir un prêt bancaire
comment également pouvoir se porter
acquéreurs d'un logement alors même que
le pouvoir d'achat est en berne et que
l'état au nom de la rigueur n'assume
plus ses missions de service public et
particulièrement celle du logement ainsi
les propriétaires comme les locataires
doivent faire face à des dépenses
courantes de logement qui augmentent
plus vite que leurs revenus
que ce soit en termes de charges d'eau
de gaz ou d'électricité
aujourd'hui d'après l'association clcv
cinq cent mille ménages présenterait des
impayés de loyer de 2 mois ou plus soit
en quatre ans une augmentation de 96 %
dans le parc privé et de 58% dans le
parc public onze ans le nombre de
jugements pour impayés de loyer ainsi
progressé de 25% selon le journal
conjoncture logement pour devenir
propriétaire de son logement en france
il vaut mieux avoir des revenus
supérieurs à la médiane des français il
s'agit donc
d'une petite minorité de nos concitoyens
qui peut y prétendre
les chiffres sont d'ailleurs accablant
entre 2007 et 2009 en accession à la
propriété des personnes à revenus moyens
a ainsi reculé de 37%
nous voyons donc bien en dehors d'une
politique sociale ambitieuse
il sera bien difficile de faciliter
l'accession à la propriété
à cette occasion je voudrais également
évoquer avec vous un élément déterminant
qui explique la difficulté liée à
l'accession à la propriété éléments qui
résident dans la spéculation foncière
galopante induite par une démission des
pouvoirs publics en dans la maîtrise du
foncier en trente ans on constate qu'une
aux 2 572% des prix du foncier
c'est pourquoi nous plaidons depuis de
nombreuses années pour une régulation
des prix et du foncier pour aboutir à
une meilleure convergence entre les prix
pratiqués et les revenus perçus par nos
concitoyens
pour en finir avec le niveau du constat
je ne peux passer sous silence la
diminution des aides à la pierre qui ont
plongé le logement dans la crise que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui c'est à
dire le manque d'au moins 900 mille
logements
pourtant dans la loi de finances que
nous allons être amenés à voter bientôt
les aides à la pierre sont encore une
fois en nette diminution passant à 500
millions cette politique récurrente de
désengagement de l'état se traduit par
le fait qu'en 2008 seuls 3 168 milles
logements ont été mises en chantier dans
le même temps la politique fiscale du
gouvernement se traduit par la
multiplication des dispositifs type
scellier ou de robien dont l'opportunité
politique et l'efficacité sociale n'ont
jamais été démontrée ces dispositifs
fixes de fiscaux ont surtout favorisé le
logement privé sur fonds publics ce qui
nous apparaît particulièrement
contestable ces dispositifs n'ont au
final servi quand embrasé la spéculation
foncière
la spéculation autour du marché de
l'immobilier le 14 septembre dernier le
président nicolas sarkozy vous même
monsieur le ministre avait présenté de
nouvelles mesures qui trouveront leur
prolongement dans la loi de finances
soit disant pour favoriser l'accession à
la propriété
mais en réalité
pour un sujet tire plus encore
l'accession dite sociale à la voracité à
la volatilité des marchés financiers
ainsi il est prévu de revenir sur la
récente déductibilité des intérêts
d'emprunt car trop budgétivore le pass
foncier seraient également supprimés
pour cause de difficultés du 1% logement
à le financer
exit enfin le prêt à taux zéro dans le
plafond avait pourtant doublé avec le
plan de relance place au nouveau prêt à
taux zéro ptz + sorte de ptz amélioré
qui pourrait concerner 380 mille
bénéficiaires en proposant des montants
et des durées prêts allant jusqu'à 30
ans se presseraient universel pour les
primo accédants et sans condition de
ressources
cette réforme aurait également le mérite
principal à vos yeux de participer à
l'effort de réduction des dépenses
publiques puisque le coût devrait
atteindre 2 6 milliards soit une
économie de 1,6 milliard par an je
trouve particulièrement intéressant à ce
sujet les propos de madame mathilde
lemoine directrice des études hsbc
france qui remarquait qu'il ne faudrait
pas que l'argent injecté dans
l'accession ne servent qu'à alimenter
une hausse des prix
quelle lucidité en vérité en réalité vos
mesures ne servent que les banques
nourrissent un système pervers et
pernicieux qui financiariste pécule et
prospère sur les difficultés sociales de
nos concitoyens les plus démunis
exacerbant au final la fringue la
fameuse fracture sociale alors qu'il ya
aujourd'hui 1,3 million de demandeurs de
logement et je le répète 770 milles
personnes en situation de surendettement
il me semble que ce débat sur
l'accession à la propriété ne répond pas
à l'urgence logement vécu et ressenti
comme une priorité par nos concitoyens
car soyons clair derrière les annonces
sur l'aide à l'accession à la propriété
c'est la case du logement social qui se
confirme l'accès au logement social et
durcit les bailleurs sont contraints de
céder une partie de leur parc au nom de
l'accession sociale à la propriété pour
le logement social on assiste à un
véritable désengagement de l'état
incarné dans la période par le hold up
sur les offices hlm de 340 millions par
an sur trois années prévues dans la loi
de finances et ce malgré le réajustement
en commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale je conclu monsieur le
président nous considérons pour notre
part que le
je mens ne doit plus être considérée
comme une marchandise les pouvoirs
publics doivent permettre doivent mettre
en place une politique publique un
service public du logement à la hauteur
des enjeux
cette politique devrait se caractériser
par la mobilisation de l'ensemble des
outils disponibles fiscalité politique
foncière rôle des banques et
interventions publiques dans ce cadre
pour notre part il nous semble
primordial de revenir sur un équilibre
plus entre aides à la pierre et aide à
la personne dans ce cadre afin
d'inverser les logiques spéculatives la
création d'un pôle public de l'habitat
se trouverait affirmé ce pôle public
permettrait de lancer le grand programme
de construction de logements et
notamment de logements sociaux dont
notre pays a besoin pour enfin garantir
à tous le droit opposable au logement
digne de notre société du 21ème siècle
merci merci ma chère collègue la parole
est à notre collègue colette lui dit
shelly pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
la parole mes chers collègues
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres mesdames et messieurs
dessinateur afin de respecter les
engagements du président de la
république vous avez fait monsieur
ministre l'accession à la propriété un
objectif politique majeure nous sommes
tous d'accord pour dire qu accéder à la
propriété est primordial pour chaque
français devrait car c'est à un puissant
ressort de promotion sociale ainsi
qu'une garantie patrimoniale essentiel
qui permet je voulais dire à mes sur
pantin entre autres de sécuriser sa
retraite sans conteste certaine mesure
où il en oeuvre par le gouvernement
telles que la déduction des intérêts
d'emprunt sous forme de crédits d'impôt
et le maintien d'éligibilité des prêts
que plus moitié dans au prêt à taux zéro
pour cent ont d'ores et déjà largement
contribué au développement de
l'accession d'entreprises étaient ainsi
grâce aux mesures votées par le
parlement depuis le 1er janvier 2003
cinq millions de français ont pu quand
même accéder à la propriété et
s'établirait aujourd'hui comme tous les
orateurs long 10 57 % des français sont
propriétaires
dans moyenne européenne et à 66% le
président mais a fixé 70%
je suis convaincu qu'on y arriverons il
est en effet incontestable que les
effets de la crise vont freiner de
manière notable on ne peut pas nier la
possible de cet acte et sans trop de nos
concitoyens se retrouve en effet reculé
du parcours résidentiel auquel pour le
temps où les aspire le conséquences
économiques et sociales d'une crise
structurelle du marché pourrait avoir en
matière de tension sur le marché locatif
privé au gré des reports des sessions
enregistrées ne doivent sûrement patrie
mort et des classes moyennes surtout les
classes moyennes ont subit fortement les
effets de cette crise il la pression
immobilière leurs dépenses contraintes
mois diane ont quasiment doublé pour
atteindre pour atteindre 40 % de leur
budget de le logement représente en
moyenne plus de 20% du budget d'un foyer
ce que quand même énorme
afin de rendre plus efficace ce
dispositif d'accession à la propriété
vous avez donc décidé de le réformer
la multiplicité des outils créés c'est
vrai au fil du temps pour rendu
peut-être peu lisible et très coûteuse
la politique d'accession et pourtant ces
mesures sont essentielles pour lutter
contre la précarisation de ce don à
l'appareil et de classes moyennes et
modestes
la réforme est donc nécessaire et je
salue pas en est témoin de le faire mais
sur mini ce travail effectué et bien sûr
pas vous même et par vos services
l'ensemble des mesures qui figurent dans
cette réforme nous seront présentés dans
le cadre du plf pour 2011 que le sénat
examinera je crois à partir du 18
novembre prochain
c'est pourquoi nous serons très
attentifs mais ce nouveau dispositif que
vous nous proposerait dans les faits
tout le monde en a parlé on soumet pas
risquer d'être redondantes
mais le ptz + qui est une nouvelle aide
phare réservé aux nouveaux propriétaires
de leur résidence principale doit
remplacer à partir du 1er janvier les
trois grands cède actuelle d'accession
le prêt à 0 % initié depuis 1995 qui
reste aujourd'hui encore un outil
primordial pour l'accession à la
propriété
en sécurisant l'apport personnel des
ménages modestes et des jeunes
primo-accédants et par conséquent les
banques elles-mêmes
il constitue un puissant soutien la
solvabilité de la demande
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous ne
pouvons qu'approuver la création c'est
de ce ptz plus cependant j'aimerais
savoir messieurs min 6 10 aides
personnelles au logement la paix
l'accession le plan d'épargne-logement
lui l' avantage je vais t'aider à ces
cinq cantons
on conseille à moins de 500 mètres des
zones de rénovation urbaine cumulable
avec le ptz seront ils humain qu'une car
nous savons que les plafonds de prix
d'achat de logements vont plus que
doubler dans certains cas horizons de la
crise dans le neuf comme pour l'ancien
il est aussi essentiel que la nouvelle
aide soit supérieure pour les ménages à
revenus modestes les classes moyennes
aussi aidé par les dispositifs actuels
voilà messieurs munichois pas je crois
pas qu'il faille pense étaient des
solutions grave que l'on peut tout faire
avec les bailleurs sociaux thiérache les
bailleurs sociaux y en a d'excellents
milan n'a de moyens il y en a moins bon
il y en a qui construisent il en est
entretiennent bien leur immeuble
il y en a un qui non seulement ne
construisent pas mais l'entretien de
même pas les leurs ce qui on en parlait
ce matin je crois au ralliement
une fois les ce bac parce qu'il ya deux
on a des appartements qui restent
vacants dans nos hlm parce que les le
bailleur ne le rénove pas suffisamment
quand ils sont dans un état lamentable
et qu'on peut difficilement se loger des
des enfants dans les chambres le plafond
moisi et cetera je crois qu'il faudrait
que vous nous aidiez par exemple quand
on parlait des petits propriétaires
passent pas les patrons du cac 40
7h petit appartement cinq ans avant la
retraite en disant on va le nourrir
ils ont fait des économies puisque
malheureusement il se retrouvait des
locataires et eux ils veulent où est
justement essayer 10 faut trouver des
locataires qui pendant deux trois quatre
ans ne payent pas le loyer ils ont la
plus grande difficulté à faire ici chez
ces locales terre pas très honnête
et que du coup on se retrouve dans
certaines villes avec des nombres
d'appartements vacants qui est quand
même assez phénoménale et je crois que
ça il faut vraiment nous ayons une
action sur ce genre de problème de la
même façon il faut que ces messieurs
repentin qui en parler ou peut-être le
p12 je crois que c'est vous il faut que
chaque élu chaque maire dans sa commune
prennent des initiatives
on peut très bien impossible à un
propriétaire privé un certain
pourcentage de logements en plus c'est
ce qui sied dans ma fille et ça marche
très bien
sinon qu'ils ont mis une amende le
contrôle de légalité de la préfecture a
laissé passer ça oui on le réclame 80
mille euros s'ils font pas 20 % de
logements plus dans un immeuble privé
qu'ils construisent je vous envoie les
délibérations et sony si vous voulez il
ça fonctionne très bien et puis voilà en
gros je dirais pour que vous ayez pour
toutes ces petites mesures qui peuvent
être et qui doivent être différents
selon les régions
quand on a beaucoup de terreur quand on
peut construire c'est vrai que là le
maire n'a pas le droit de faire ce qu'il
doit
après il ya des difficultés mais on va
quand il ya un permis de construire qui
vient d'un privé qui dit je vais faire
60 logements parce qu'il a déjà jeté
terrain qui débarque pour sa demande de
permis de construire à la mairie foudre
la morale permis que quand il aura voilà
donc monsieur rémy ni simplement nous
serons là avec vous nous vous
soutiendrons avec nos collègues du
groupe ump dans la région
la réalisation de cet objectif ambitieux
pour que notre pays ne soit plus à la
traîne de la moyenne européenne et merci
merci ma chère collègue
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
claude jeannerot pour le groupe
socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'article
56 du projet de loi de finances pour
2011 propose la création d'un nouveau
prêt à taux zéro renforcé au service
vous le savez d'une ambition portée par
le président de la république la france
des propriétaires
trois aspects positifs et clair ce
projet je veux les souligné d'abord
incontestablement il apporte un élément
de simplification dans les aides de
l'état au sein d'un système caractérisé
il faut bien le reconnaître par une
complexité croissante des circuits de
financement de la politique du logement
et je crois qu'on peut en espérer une
lisibilité et une efficacité accrue
ensuite le nouveau système recentre
l'aide là où elle est nécessaire et
s'inscrit dans un souci écologique
l'aide serait en effet renforcé pour les
achats en zone tendue et les montants
varieront selon qu'il s'agit d'un
logement respectueux de l'environnement
bien sûr du convient d'en savoir plus
sur les modalités
sans doute ne manquerez vous pas
monsieur le ministre de nous éclairer
dans la communication que vous nous
ferez car nous savons bien que ce sont
les modalités qui sont décisives et qui
conditionne la réussite d'un dispositif
enfin troisième point on ne peut que se
réjouir de la suppression du crédit
d'impôt sur les intérêts d'emprunt vous
le savez les socialistes requiert
d'ailleurs depuis bien longtemps
la fin de ces niches fiscales et ce
crédit d'impôt provoquèrent un double
effet pervers il coûte cher celui là il
coûte cher à l'état
de plus en plus cher 280 millions en
2008 et la projection que nous pouvions
faire nous conduisait à 3 milliards en
2013 et on sait de plus c'est ça qui
condamne cette news
on sait que elle ne bénéficie pas à ceux
qui en ont vraiment besoin et pour une
aide qui n'a aucun effet sur le
déclenchement de la décision d'achat
convenait que ceci est très coûteux
d'autant qu'elle ne correspond
finalement qu'à une baisse de 0 6% du
taux d'intérêt contractées par les
acheteurs sur l'attention que vous
portez à savoir favoriser l'accession à
la propriété
nous ne pouvons évidemment que la
partager il est normal que l'état crée
les conditions les plus favorables pour
permettre cet accès à la propriété
d'ailleurs l'article 2 de la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen
dispose que la propriété est l'un des
droits naturels et imprescriptibles de
l'homme les j'observe d'ailleurs comme
président de l' agence nationale pour
l'information sur le logement je peux en
témoigner que l'accès à la propriété en
effet correspond à une aspiration
majoritaire des ménages et tout
particulièrement des ménages modestes en
même temps mes chers collègues soyons en
conscients
jamais la situation n'a été aussi
défavorable la baisse du taux conjuguée
à l'allongement de la durée des prêts
n'y suffit pas l'envolée des prix créé
beaucoup de désillusions y compris au
sein de la classe moyenne et vous avez
pu lire récemment dans un article grand
public que thierry debes remparts l'est
pour la classe moyenne
une vraie peur du déclassement le
logement marqueur social par excellence
et risquerait selon lui de devenir un
facteur de paupérisation des classes
moyennes car celles ci continuent de
choisir parmi l'offre la plus coûteuse
du marché tentait de progresser
quitte à s'endetter au delà du
raisonnable ou à acheter trop petit
c'est pourquoi il ne me paraît pas
réaliste
dans le contexte de fixer un objectif de
68 à 70 % de propriétaires
je doute en réalité de l'effet dynamique
d'un tel chiffre
pire il risque
découragé ceux qui sont loin de pouvoir
y accéder et dans un contexte où les
besoins seraient par ailleurs satisfait
ce chiffre pourrait peut-être traduire
une volonté mais pour tout dire la
question du logement nécessite
aujourd'hui dans son ensemble un grand
plan marshall et cet objectif de cet
objectif d'accès à la propriété
dans ce contexte paraît dérisoire et
décalé alors j'en reviens à votre projet
j'en ai souligné les aspects positifs
simplification renforcer dimension
écologique est aussi l'économie qu'il
permet par la suppression du crédit
d'impôt mais comme jeanny comme janus
votre projet comporte un double visage
et dans son versant négatif
le fait de rendre le prêt à taux zéro
universel me paraît lourdement
dommageable et du coup le rang par
certains aspects inopportun inefficace
et injuste
en effet ce nouveau prêt à taux zéro
renforcé
s'adressant aux primo-accédants pour
leur résidence principale n'est soumis à
aucune condition de ressources
bien que les modalités du prêt je vous
le concède diffèrent en fonction des
revenus et de la nature du lien acheter
dans le contexte de restrictions
budgétaires
votre proposition de ce point de vue
nous paraît inopportune à l'heure où la
ministre de l'économie a estimé que les
gouvernements devaient désormais
s'orienter vers des politiques de
réduction des dépenses pour
contrebalancer les mesures de soutien à
l'économie mises en oeuvre pendant la
crise économique
n'est-il pas contradictoire d'ouvrir le
bénéfice du prêt à taux zéro à des
personnes dont le revenu ne le
justifient pas rendez vous compte
monsieur le ministre la perte de
recettes fiscales pour l'état
recettes fiscales pour l'état dus aux
deux tranches supérieures du barème de
prêt à taux zéro est évalué à 400
millions de
et sous cet aspect votre projet me
semble inefficace il ne peut avoir en
effet aucun effet aucune aucun impact
sur la décision d'accéder des ménages
aisés et ne représente c'est le risque
qu un effet d'aubaine
elle correspond à une politique qui tend
à favoriser les plus prospères à créer
des avantages pour ceux qui n'en n'ont
pas besoin et sous cet aspect cette
mesure est inefficace
enfin votre proposition est injuste et
j'ai compris d'ailleurs dans les propos
de mon collègue jean françois mayet
qu'il nous rejoigne est elle est injuste
à l'égard de ceux qui n'ont pas de
revenus suffisants pour accéder à la
propriété
je note que parmi ces personnes
auxquelles les revenus interdisent de
devenir propriétaire nombreux sont logés
dans le parc social auquel le
gouvernement voulait imposer un nouveau
prélèvement l'article 99 du projet de
loi de finances prévoyait en effet d'un
système institué un prélèvement sur les
ressources financières des organismes
hlm fondée sur leur assujettissement à
la contribution sur les revenus locatifs
or la non extension du nouveau prêt à
taux zéro aux revenus les plus élevés
aurait permis précisément de réaliser
l'économie recherché à travers le
prélèvement sur les loyers hlm
ce nouveau prêt à taux zéro est donc un
cadeau sans efficacité pour les plus
aisés est un pied-de-nez pour les
locataires hlm
ce qui est profondément choquant au
besoin d'eux au delà de ses critiques
votre réforme continue de soulever un
certain nombre d'interrogations
d'abord répond-t-elle aux besoins de
sécurisation financière en particulier
sous l'angle des risques de
surendettement l'accès au crédit
surtout dans un contexte où le marché de
l'emploi était est très dégradé ne
risque-t-elle pas mécaniquement de
majorer les risques techniques de
surendettement des ménages
quels sont les garde-fous
aujourd'hui j'observe que seuls 5 % des
emprunteurs en cours de remboursement
sont couverts par une assurance chômage
et même si je souhaite saluer salué le
rôle d agence départementale pour
l'information sur le logement et la
grande compétence de leurs personnels
qui joue un rôle vous le savez essentiel
au service de la sécurisation des
projets immobiliers
je m'interroge sur la question de savoir
s'il ne convient pas d'aller un peu plus
loin dans la recherche de mesures
concrètes et opérationnelles
enfin il convient de s'interroger sur
l'efficacité de vos propositions au
service de la mobilité résidentielle
je ne reviendrai pas sur les
propositions du centre d'analysé
stratégique évoqué tout à l'heure mon
collègue thierry repentin
il formule un certain nombre de
propositions notamment sur le champ
fiscal
je vous pose la question savoir les
suites que vous entendez leurs données
bref c'est l'opportunité aujourd'hui de
regarder votre projet de loi sur
l'accession à la propriété dans ses
différents aspects mais le secteur du
logement a besoin au delà de cet aspect
d'une grande politique de relance je
termine monsieur le président d'un grand
plan marshall je l'évoquais pour tenter
de résoudre le déséquilibre persistant
et pour éviter que la crise ne devienne
irréversible et j'entendais ces jours
derniers le premier ministre jean pierre
raffarin réclamait un double plan sur
l'emploi et sur le logement
tout se tient c'est l'urgence c'est
l'avenir c'est la préoccupation première
de nos concitoyens l'emploi et le
logement 2 préalable absolu je vous
remercie
merci mon cher collègue dans un gottéron
la parole monsieur le président merci
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
c'est vrai que le président de la
république a donné une feuille de route
extrêmement ambitieuse en matière
d'accession à la propriété
j'ai bien entendu ce qui a été dit par
les orateurs précédents
moi je veux insister quand même certes
sur la le caractère disons ambitieux
l'objectif mais aussi sur sa valeur
sociale quand même parce que il me
semble que à travers cet objectif c'est
un vrai projet de société call président
de la république et qu'il s'agit de
constituer un peu de renforcer la
cohésion de notre société
c'est ainsi qu'il faut comprendre cet
objectif un objectif mobilisateur alors
certes il ya beaucoup d'étapes
d'affranchir pour l'atteindre monsieur
le ministre on le sait bien il faut
d'abord redonner confiance à l'ensemble
des ménages dans un climat économique
encore dégradée affaibli par la timide
reprise la croissance la faible
progression anticipée du pouvoir d'achat
la pression du chômage l'augmentation
des déficits publics
il faut aussi développer une offre de
logements économiquement accessible une
offre diversifiée une offre équilibrée
c'est dans ce contexte que la réforme
des aides à l'accession s'imposait
notamment dans le cadre du projet de loi
de finances pour 2011 que nous allons
bientôt examiner tout en tenant compte
de la rigueur budgétaire imposée par le
poids des déficits publics
la reconfiguration dézinguer des aides
existantes doit permettre de réconcilier
les lainages avec l'investissement dans
la pierre et de développer l'accession à
la propriété notamment sociales afin de
rénover le parc hlm
cependant le marché de l'ancien et je
vais parler un peu des zones rurales
monsieur le ministre
oui le marché de l'ancien ne doit pas
être le parent pauvre de la réforme et
j'aimerais sans insister trop monsieur
le ministre - vous dire que je
souhaiterais avoir des précisions sur
les intentions du gouvernement sur ce
chemin comme beaucoup comme beaucoup ici
je suis maire d'une petite commune
rurale et je constate que dans nos
bourgs beaucoup d'immeubles un certain
nombre d'immeubles on le sait bien ne
sont pas habités sont désaffectés les
organismes dash l amo clients auxquels
on fait facilement appel ont atteint
leurs limites très souvent et
considèrent qu'ils ne peuvent plus
prendre en charge la réhabilitation de
ces logements
mais je pense monsieur le ministre qu'on
a dans nos communes est de plus en plus
des gens qui seraient capables de
devenir propriétaire qui le
souhaiteraient mais à qui mes acquis
effectivement manque un peu les moyens
parce que la charge est lourde
on trouverait des vendeurs les
propriétaires parfois sont vendeurs ils
se rendent bien compte que leur leur
immeuble ils ne peuvent pas le briser
une peu plus l'utiliser et malgré
l'attachement patrimonial à leurs biens
ils sont souvent prêts à vendre mais on
est bloqué il faut réellement monsieur
le ministre que dans des zones comme
celle dont j'ai la charge dans un
département comme le mien vous donniez à
ceux qui veulent devenir propriétaires
la possibilité de l'avenir et de trouver
les financements pour en revenir à la
réforme proposée par le gouvernement le
prêt à taux zéro + qui doit remplacer à
compter du 1er janvier prochain les
trois grands dette actuelle d'accession
à la propriété
ce prêt à taux zéro bien entendu mérite
d'être j'allais dire plébiscité jeu
j'observe d'ailleurs que
fondamentalement il ya des critiques
il ya des réserves mais il n'y a pas de
critique fondamentale sur le principe
même du preuve ce financement restera
indispensable pour permettre aux jeunes
de moins de 35 ans ce qu'il s'agit de 50
% des bénéficiaires aux catégories
socioprofessionnelles les moins aisés et
aux catégories intermédiaires d'accéder
à la propriété
toujours considéré comme tel depuis sa
création en 95 le prêt à taux zéro reste
un puissant levier pour la relance de
l'activité de construction pour autant
c'est dans l'ancien que la mesure est la
plus efficace et permet au plus grand
nombre de français d'être propriétaires
de leur logement la mise en place d'un
taux à taux zéro renforcé le p
z plus apparaît comme une évidence
aujourd'hui pour remplir pleinement son
rôle social pour encourager pour
déclencher véritablement des projets
d'accession à la propriété notamment
chez les ménages modestes
il faut donc pour garantir l'efficacité
la justice sociale du dispositif que ce
prêt puisse être modulée en fonction de
la taille des ressources des ménages de
la typologie des accédants et de la zone
géographique des opérations financées
j'ai bien entendu ce qu'a dit tout à
l'heure notre collègue monsieur genro
qui était d'ailleurs tout à fait
équilibré le dire que son discours était
tout à fait équilibrée mais il a insisté
sur le fait que certains ménages
considéré comme disons aisés n'a
peut-être pas besoin du prêt à taux zéro
plus sauf que il y à des zones où il l'a
dit lui même les prix sont très élevés
et pour permettre l'accession à la
propriété des ménages même relativement
aisé on
ils auront besoin ces ménages n'a du
prêt à taux zéro plus donc il faut
moduler me semble-t-il mon chat
collègues genro ce que me permets de
vous interpeller parce que votre propos
étaient tout à fait je le redis
équilibré et mérite d'être pris en
considération
c'est un vrai dialogue un échange entre
nous je crois qu'il faut tenir compte du
zonage et de moduler ce que vous avez
dit en en tenant compte notre économie a
été on ne s'est mise à mal et il est
vrai que la construction de logements
neufs peine à sortir de la crise les
promoteurs comme les particuliers
restent prudents cependant il faut
rester confiant sur l'évolution à terme
du secteur du bâtiment
car les mesures prises depuis deux ans
ont heureusement permis aux entreprises
de préserver un outil de production
performant nécessaire 1 re démarrage à
moyen terme et je veux à ce moment non
propose salué les entreprises devront
département qui effectivement je crois
ont tenu le coup et traversé la crise
dans des conditions douloureuses pour
elle mais qui leur permettront de faire
face à la reprise
je veux donc salué la réforme des aides
à l'accession à la propriété qui est la
bienvenue en cette période de sortie de
crise bien entendu monsieur le ministre
avec mes collègues cela a été dit par
mme après décès cerise tout à l'heure
connaître du dit c'est dit
nous apporterons notre total soutien à
vos propositions lors de l'examen du
projet de loi de finances pour 2012
merci monsieur le président la parole
est maintenant un autre collègue marie
hélène des esgaulx pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire v la parole
ma chère collègue ces présidents
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
l'article 55 de la loi du 13 décembre
2000 tout le monde connaît relative à la
solidarité et au renouvellement urbains
et qui donne obligation aux communes
dans la population est au moins égal à
1500 habitants en ile-de-france et 3500
habitants dans les autres régions
d'avoir une proportion de 20% de
logements sociaux sur leur territoire
favorable à une évolution de la loi pour
que l'on tienne compte dans ce
pourcentage de 20% des efforts faits par
les communes pour aider les ménages les
plus modestes à devenir propriétaires le
législateur de 2006 a estimé souhaitable
que l'accession sociale à la propriété
soit prise en compte dans le décompte de
20% mais seulement pour une période de
cinq ans le législateur de 2006 a donc
considéré comme totalement légitime le
fait que ces logements sociaux puissent
continuer à être comptabilisé dans le
quota des 20 % puisque ces logements ne
perde en aucun cas leur caractère social
malgré le changement de statut de leurs
occupants il a cependant souhaité
limiter dans le temps soit pendant cinq
ans cette possibilité je souhaiterais
que l'on distingue bien les logements
construits dans le but dès le départ de
l'accession à la propriété des logements
hlm acquis par leurs occupants dans les
conditions fixées notamment de durée
d'occupation dix ans je crois c'est tout
à fait différent il y aurait beaucoup à
dire bien sûr sur le premier point sur
l'accession voulu dès le départ mais moi
je vais me concentrer mais sa ministre
sur le deuxième cas qui est donc
l'acquisition par l'occupant au bout
d'un certain temps un effet favorisé
l'accession sociale à la propriété en
permettant à des personnes de condition
modeste locataires
logements hlm de devenir propriétaire et
d'améliorer ainsi la mixité sociale la
commune
c'est vraiment un objectif noble et qui
répond à une demande de la population
mais également au souhait du président
de la république qui s'est prononcé pour
l'encouragement à la propriété de la
résidence principale
or le problème pour les communes qui
accepte les demandes de leurs habitants
et comment on ne peut refuser une
demande d'un habitant une telle demande
d'acquérir leur logement bien c'est que
ces communes souvent par là même
pénalisé financièrement au bout de cinq
ans par la diminution automatique du
quota de logements sociaux que de telles
ventes donc d'entraîner
moi je trouve ce cas bien étrange
pourquoi pénaliser les communes dans ce
cas là alors qu'elles n'y sont
strictement pour rien que la demande
d'acquisition et man soit de l'organisme
hlm soit de l'occupant en tout cas
jamais de la commune
l'occupant y trouve bien évidemment son
compte il devient propriétaire
c'est le rêve de toutes les familles et
c'est la première des sécurités et je
voudrais faire observer que si on dit
dans la langue logement social n'a pas
vocation à être l'habitat de toute une
vie dans les faits permettez-moi de
remarquer qu'il est quand même bien
souvent n'organise hlm nous aussi trouve
son compte
il reçoit le prix de vente en
contrepartie et grâce à la rotation et
grâce à cela il ya une rotation des
logements sociaux qui peut être mis en
oeuvre je sais combien monsieur le
ministre vous êtes attachés vous êtes
exprimé dans ce sens dans cet hémicycle
sur la rotation des logements sociaux
mais là permettez moi de vous dire
qu'elle peut parfaitement être respectée
parce qu'avec le prix de vente
le bailleur social peut parfaitement
réinvestir le ce prix dans la
construction de notre logis mort et moi
je pense même qu'on devrait l'obliger et
ça me paraîtrait une chose assez assez
saine et que vient faire à la commune
d'agde nombre elle a déjà un objectif
qui est difficile à atteindre et ensuite
on lui impose des paramètres qui ne
dépas qui ne dépendent pas elle moi j'ai
dit impose parce que franchement comment
peut-on imaginer une seconde que les
communes
refuse à leurs habitants à devenir
acquéreur c'est impossible sont les
jambes qui ont fait des investissements
dans l'eure dans leur maison qui ont
obtenu le fion ce monde pour ça et vous
voyez un maire dira cette personne est
bien non moi je vous autorise pas
devenir propriétaire parce que voyez
vous ces logements ils comptent plus
normé logements sociaux c'est tout
simplement absurde et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vous ai demandé dès le
départ devient vouloir distinguer si
l'école et logements qui ont été
construits dans le guide des parts dans
le but de l'accession à la propriété et
les autres
les autres ce sont des logements qui
étaient dans le secteur locatif
le maire a fait tout ce qu'il fallait
pour ça il a payé souvent une surcote
foncière il a donné des terrains il a
fait un travail considérable et là dans
ce cas précis parce que c'est quelque
chose que personne ne peut reprocher et
bien là on va le pénaliser et on va
faire en sorte que les logements ne
compte de plus au bout de cinq gains
d'un logement c'est totalement absurde
alors un peu plus de souplesse monsieur
le ministre
dans ce cas très particulier qui je le
redis ne vise pas la totalité de
l'accession à la propriété
ça ne remettrait nullement en cause le
sacro-saint article 55 de la loi sru est
toujours dans ce cas particulier
je fais observer qu'il n'y a pas du tout
un usage abusif de la procédure de
l'accession sociale puisque elle est
imposée à la au maire de plus il n'est
pas normal fait pour moi il n'est pas
normal que logements hlm acquis par
leurs occupants ayant bénéficié du prêt
social de location accession reste
définitivement dans le parc social
très franchement moi je trouve pas ça du
tout son corps alors on peut bien sûr
mon exact et le cas rare d'une revente
du logement et bien sûr on peut
l'envisager se dit pas que c'est un cas
d'école mais ça peut ça peut
effectivement existé par exemple
quelqu'un qui achète était locataire qui
deviennent propriétaires dans les
conditions que je vais me rappeler
qu'ils décèdent
il ya des héritiers il ya une succession
et y vende yvonne logement dans ce cas
moi ça ne me choquerait absolument pas
qu'à ce moment là
l'affectation sociale du logement
disparaissent à cette occasion en tout
cas c'est ce sont des choses que l'on
peut régler tout à fait normalement chez
ministre assez pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons que je vais développer
il me paraît nécessaire de tenir compte
de cette situation très particulière en
supprimant pour elle pour cette
situation-là la période transitoire de
cinq ans ou un ou deux je dirai tout à
tout le moins dans un premier temps de
l'allonger moi je propose de l'allonger
par exemple à 10 ans j'ose espérer de
votre part monsieur le ministre une
attention toute particulière aux
problèmes soulevés un moment où on ne
peut que constater le lourd déficit du
nombre de constructions
le renchérissement des loyers et des
prix de l'immobilier et que la crise du
logement touche tout le monde donc et
puis que les collectivités locales
disons le bas elles ont de faibles
marges de manoeuvre en tout cas je
remercie particulièrement monsieur jean
françois mayet qui grâce à cette
question orale avec débat m'a permis de
poser ce problème je l'en remercie comme
je remercie de votre attention
merci ma chère collègue
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
raymond couderc pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
c'est le président remercie monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
possibilité d'acquérir son logement
s'inscrit dans une inspiration légitimes
des jeunes ménages et devrait marquer
une étape essentielle dans un parcours
résidentiel
elle correspond à la volonté du
président de la république de faire une
france de propriétaires
elle participe également et ce n'est pas
négligeable au maintien d'une activité
économique primordial pour le territoire
que sont le bâtiment et les travaux
publics
c'est pourquoi nous remercions jean
françois mayet de nous inviter à nous
pencher sur ce sujet et notamment sur
les dispositifs en faveur de l'accession
abordable la propriété en effet depuis
la loi du 13 juillet 2006 portant
engagement national pour le logement
une douzaine de dispositifs ont été mis
en place ou renforcé pour aider les
ménages primo-accédants et plus
particulièrement ceux à faibles
ressources
ces dispositifs que nous connaissons
tous comme le prêt à taux zéro le pass
foncier mais aussi les plus anciens
l'épargne-logement les crédits d'impôt
ou encore l'aide personnelle au logement
sont autant d'outils mis à disposition
des français jeu dans mon point
d'observation qui est ma communauté
d'agglomération je peux dire que c'est
quelque chose qui marche bien puisque au
cours des 18 derniers mois
cela a permis à 139 ménages de
d'acquérir leur leur maison ou leur
logement
les collectivités locales sont souvent
venus aux côtés de l'état dans ses
actions et depuis 18 mois ma
collectivité ma communauté
d'agglomération a consacré près de
quatre cent cinquante cinq mille euros
pour aider à l'accession abordable à la
propriété
donc les résultats sont loin d'être
négligeables
contrairement à ce qui peut se dire ici
ou là où l'on entend beaucoup de
scepticisme sur ces mesures
si cette action s'est avérée très
positive ces dernières années par contre
la diminution du doublement du prêt à
taux zéro et la baisse de 20 mille euros
des plafonds du pass foncier au second
semestre 2010 non plus permis de
solvabiliser une partie des primo
accédants ce qui entraîne aujourd'hui
une diminution du nombre de dossiers de
demandes dead à ma collectivité et ceci
dans un contexte que nous connaissons
tous de crise financière et de pression
immobilière à partir du 1er janvier 2011
le prêt à taux zéro + ou taux zéro
renforcé doit entrer en vigueur il va
faire disparaître la majorité ration du
prêt à taux zéro le crédit d'impôt sur
les intérêts d'emprunt et le pass
foncier
ce nouvel outil financier qui se veut
plus simple et plus utiles restera
réservé aux primo-accédants mais ne sera
plus soumis comme l'était les anciens
outils aux conditions de ressources de
critères doivent être mises en avant
pour son attribution
le nombre de personnes composant le
foyer et la zone géographique d'achat du
bien
c'est sur ce second point que je
voudrais insister si l'on considère ces
nouveaux critères de nombreuses
agglomérations de villes moyennes comme
mon agglomération
du biterrois par exemple apparaîtrait en
zone b2 c'est à dire en zones moins
tendue aussi en foyer de cinq personnes
dans cette zone pourrait bénéficier
d'une aide 298 1000 euros alors quand
sonnera s'étendirent en zone tendue et
je ne conteste pas le fait qu'il y ait
des zones plus tendue certes c'était de
sueur est équivalente à 3 159 milles
euros pour 5 personnes pour un logement
neuf
c'est la différence pour une famille dès
lors de 80 % plus élevé dans les grandes
villes en zone aux actes dans les villes
moyennes en zone b et cela sans tenir
compte bien sur des revenus des foyers
de plus et malgré l'effort fourni pour
relancer les quartiers anciens et les
centres bourgs
il en a été question tout à l'heure il
n'en reste pas moins que l'aide proposée
par le prêt à taux zéro + correspond à
une perte de pouvoir d'achat pour les
foyers en effet à d'aussi équivalent le
prêt à taux zéro plus offrira des aides
inférieur aux habitants des villes
moyennes par rapport à ce que permettait
les douze dispositif dead au premier
semestre 2010 il est dès lors logique de
se demander si la population résidant
dans les villes moyennes et par exemple
dans ma communauté d'agglomération 70%
de la population est éligible au
logement sociaux
si cette population continuera à se
tourner vers 7 ou 10 outils financiers
pour devenir propriétaire et de se
questionner sur l'impact économique qui
en résulteraient le cas échéant
notamment dans le domaine du bâtiment et
des travaux publics
merci mon cher collègue bien pour
répondre aux orateurs et à l'auteur de
la question orale
la parole est maintenant monsieur
benoist apparu secrétaire d'état chargé
du logement et de l'urbanisme
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je voudrais tout d'abord remercier
jean-françois mayet d'avoir bien voulu
demander l'inscription à l'ordre du jour
de ce débat aujourd'hui sur l'accession
à la propriété
c'est je crois comme lui une question
absolument majeur pour notre pays et
plus généralement pour la politique du
logement
nous avons eu l'occasion d'en discuter
ensemble à plusieurs reprises et je sais
que nous partageons globalement la même
analyse sur ce sujet là je voudrais
répondre bien évidemment différentes
interprétations du sénateur maillet et
de l'ensemble et sénateurs mais avant
peut-être vous dire quelques mots sur la
réformes que nous avons engagées et qui
me permettra d'ailleurs de répondre à un
certain nombre d'interpellations tout
était fait
le 14 septembre dernier le président de
la république a présenté les grandes
lignes de cette réforme de l'accession à
la propriété
quelles sont elles nous avons souhaité
très clairement avoir un système plus
simple en réduisant le nombre des death
a été soulignée nous avons souhaité un
système plus efficace pour faire
progresser le nombre de propriétaires
nous avons souhaité un système qui
soutiennent la construction ce qui n'est
pas le cas des outils actuels et puis
nous avons souhaité un indice positif
évidemment écologique enfin un autre
élément très important si ce n'est le
plus important de ce nouveau dispositif
un dispositif qui épousent la réalité
des prix sur notre territoire et des
différences de prix fort notre
territoire j'y reviendrai suite à
l'interprétation bien évidemment du
sénateur couderc ce nouveau dispositif a
donc cette volonté d'avoir un produit
beaucoup plus efficace qu'aujourd'hui au
lieu d'investir 1,2 milliard d'euros
nous investirons 2,6 me
d'euros dans le prêt à taux zéro plus
nous allons avoir un produit qui sera
mieux familialiser qu'aujourd'hui et
nous allons maintenir parallèlement à ça
d'autres outils d'accession à la
propriété qui sont des niches très
particulière je pense notamment à la tva
à 5,5 en zone en rue ou ps et là je
voudrais également vous dire que nous
allons parallèlement et c'est un enjeu
essentiel de cette réforme
agir sur les prix si demain on se
contente de faire cette réforme de
l'accession à la propriété sans avoir
une action sur la politique foncière et
sur la politique d'urbanisme
cette réforme n'aura qu'une conséquence
c'est alimenter les prix de l'immobilier
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis à
titre personnel mais totalement opposé à
une préconisation qui a été fait tout à
l'heure
d'avoir la généralisation d'une tva à
5,5 sur l'immobilier pluie le produit
est universel plus le produit est
identique m'avait semblé pour les foyers
les plus modestes vous aviez présente
proposer une tva à 5,5 mais je vous le
dis tout de suite une tva à 5,5
ça n'a qu'un impact c'est directement
sur les prix et donc sincèrement j'en
tirerai la transe de votre attention
le produit totalement identique
totalement uniforme type baisse des
droits de mutation ou type tva à 5,5 ça
n'a malheureusement qu'une conséquence
alimenterait le facteur prix c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons refusé
tout en étudiant évidemment ces deux
mesures la droits de mutation d'un côté
tva à 5,5
nous n'avons pas souhaité aller dans
cette direction là il n'en demeure pas
moins que le produit que nous a que nous
présentons dans le cadre du projet doit
finances à savoir le ptz + est également
un produit qui peut alimenter les prix
il va feindre il va nous falloir donc
parallèlement à ça avoir une action
foncière et une action en matière
d'urbanisme très importante si nous
souhaitons éviter que cette réforme se
traduise là encore par une aubade rouler
prix pourquoi tout simplement parce que
si on fait cette réforme
comme plusieurs d'entre vous l'ont
indiqué tout à l'heure c'est bien parce
qu'il y a depuis une quinzaine d'années
une désolvabilisation d'une grande
partie des ménages et notamment des
classes moyennes vous avez évoqué les
chiffres les uns et les autres depuis
1985 95 pardon les prix de l'immobilier
ont été multipliées par 2,5
parallèlement à ça le pouvoir d'achat le
groupe a toutefois lâché par dont
l'augmentation des salaires
ça a été x 1,6 autrement dit x 2,5 pour
les prix de l'immobilier x 1,6 pour les
revenus le résultat c'est évidemment une
désolvabilisation importante de la
classe moyenne
c'est bien la raison pour laquelle nous
souhaitons aujourd'hui conformément aux
engagements du président république
pendant sa campagne présidentielle
engagé cette réforme pour re
solvabiliser via ce nouveau prêt à taux
zéro les casses moyenne notamment leur
permettre de redevenir propriétaire
parce que là encore en terme d'ambitions
philosophique
je ne crois pas qu est propriétaire
c'est être conservateur je crois qu'il
est un élément de sécurité pour les uns
et pour les autres je crois que c'est
également un élément de préparation de
retraite
c'est un élément pour se constituer un
patrimoine et transmettre son patrimoine
bref c'est un élément est évidemment
essentiel dans la vie quotidienne de nos
compatriotes j'ai maintenant si vous le
voulez bien revenir à ce nombre de
questions qui ont été posées la france
de propriétaires qui avaient évoqué le
président de la république c'était une
ambition c'était un vrai projet de
société
ce projet de société ne signifiait pas
bien évidemment que 100% de nos
compatriotes soient propriétaires
ce serait une grave erreur j'y
reviendrai dans un instant cette
ambition d'une france de propriétaires
c'était pour nous essayer d'aboutir
globalement à la moyenne européenne peu
ou prou 66 % de propriétaires
alors bien évidemment on peut prendre
des exemples
venus notamment des pays de l'est qui
ont été cités tout à l'heure par le
sénateur pantin mais nous n'avons jamais
souhaité avoir 82 83 85 % de propriétés
en france ce serait effectivement une
erreur en termes de mobilité et vous
avez cité monsieur le sénateur
effectivement les analyses récentes du
conseil d analyse stratégique indiquant
qu'il y avait une forme de corrélation
entre le taux de chômage d'un côté et
des taux trop élevé de propriétaires
parce qu'on sait bien qu'un taux de
propriétaires à 85% freine la mobilité
professionnelle
donc de ce point de vue là pas de procès
d'intention
personne n'a infirmé qu'on souhaitait
rejoindre les champions européens de la
propriété personne n'a souhaité affirmer
que nous voulions 85 % de propriétaires
nous avons considéré qu 1,6 qui tournait
autour des deux tiers de nos
compatriotes propriétaire était un
chiffre intéressant qui rejoignait la
moyenne européenne mais qui nous
préserver des difficultés en termes de
mobilité d'un côté et de l'autre faisait
également pouffer l'accès à la propriété
quelques propos en réponse au sénateur
maillé je suis d'accord avec vous sur le
fond il faut que le monde hlm rentrer de
plain-pied dans la vente à leurs
locataires
c'est un enjeu là encore de société très
important un enjeu de société parce
qu'il serait socialement totalement
inadmissible que nous concentrions notre
action exclusivement sur les classes
moyennes ou sur les plus riches
il faut que les plus modestes de nos
compatriotes ceux notamment qui vivent
en hlm puissent également accéder à la
propriété
alors c'est vrai qu'ils peuvent accéder
à la propriété en dehors du parc hlm et
on les y aide via ses prêts à taux zéro
mais pour eux accéder à la propriété
dans le monde hlm est doublement
facilité facilité parce que dans cette
réforme
on va mettre 5 % de plus pour ceux qui
vont acheter leur logement mais
faciliter également puisque dans les
lois précédentes
chacun sait bien que lorsqu'on vend un
hlm
il y à une décote possible
35 % par rapport à aux prix du marché du
logement en question
autrement dit ça veut dire qu'un
locataires hlm qui achète son logement
il à l'ensemble des outils type le prêt
à taux zéro et notamment ce nouveau prêt
à taux zéro dans le cadre de la réforme
il a 5 % de plus dead mais en plus il a
une décote de son logement qui peut
aller jusqu'à 35%
donc ça veut dire clairement que les
plus modestes de nos compatriotes qui
sont logés en logements hlm entre la
décote et le prêt à taux zéro ont une
aide absolument formidable pour devenir
propriétaire je crois que c'est un enjeu
absolument essentiel qu'il nous faut
encourager les uns et les autres mais je
sais et je serai peut-être moins
pessimiste que vous et que certains
d'entre vous que le moine hlm partage
totalement cette analyse puisque ils ont
évidemment signé un certain nombre de
conventions avec l'état s'engageant à
vendre 1% du parc hlm par an c'est vrai
que si le 1% en question pouvaient être
non pas simplement un objectif mais une
réalité ce serait plus intéressant nous
ne sommes pas encore là puisqu'on n'est
pas un pour cent mais à 0,1 pour cent
donc il faut qu'on fasse x 10 pour
respecter les engagements qui sont les
nôtres et qui sont ceux du monde hlm
mais bien évidemment j'ai une confiance
absolue dans le monde hlm pour le
respect de sa signature en la matière
monsieur repentin quelques mots j'avoue
que j'ai trouvé votre démonstration sur
la mobilité exceptionnelle
1 vous prenez des chiffres qui sont ceux
de l'allemagne de l'est
ex satellites de l'est pour dire
regardez ça marchera pas j'avoue être
surpris que vous ne citiez la roumanie
que vous citiez les huitièmes où vous
situez tous ces pays là en disant
regardez ils sont à 85 % de
propriétaires et ça ne les empêche pas
d'avoir un taux de chômage parmi les
plus importants de l'union européenne je
vous répète notre objectif n'a jamais
été de la 80% mais monsieur repentin
surtout j'avoue que votre plaidoyer pour
la mobilité
je ne peux que le partager je
souhaiterais simplement que cette
mobilité on la retrouve également dans
le monde hlm
vous avez raison l'absence de mobilité
est un frein au développement de
l'emploi dont acte
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
je partage votre analyse n'hésitez
surtout pas à faire de la mobilité dans
le monde hlm un de vos enjeux je crois
que vous êtes président lui s h et je
sais que je pourrai compter sur vous à
l'avenir pour engager également cette
mobilité au sein du parc hlm en
pourcentage on pourra effectivement
comparer les chiffres vous êtes à 10%
mobilité si mes souvenirs sont bons
parents je vous rappelle juste un
chiffre monsieur le président dix pour
cent de mobilité au moins un hlm
si on passait le taux de mobilité dans
le monde hlm de 10 % à 15 % 15 % se
serait pas considérable ça voudrait dire
ça voudrait dire une chose
passée la mobilité de 10% à 15% ça
voudrait dire 200 mille offres de
logements supplémentaires par an on
construit cent mille logements dans
notre pays sa part dont on finance en
mille logements sociaux notre pays 140
milles j'espère en 2010 120 mille en
2009 le record depuis 30 ans je vous
rappelle les chiffres entre 1978 et 2003
droite et gauche confondues on finançait
cinquante mille logements sociaux par an
depuis 2004 on est à cent mille salles
effort massif
c'est un effort massif de la part des
collectivités locales des bailleurs
sociaux et de l'état et c'est cette
mobilisation de l'ensemble des acteurs
qui nous a permis d'atteindre ces
chiffres cent mille par an mais si on
améliore la mobilité en passant de 10000
à 15000 ces deux cent mille deux cent
mille offres nouvelles par an et là avec
un coup avec un coût 2 0%
ni pour les bailleurs ni pour l'état ni
pour les collectivités locales
deux cent mille d'un côté contre 100
milles de l'autre nous avons un effort
majeur à faire en matière de mobilité et
je sais que je peux compter sur vous
pour y arriver vous luz monsieur le
sénateur repentent 1 vous évoquez
également cette question de lune hervé
l'universalité pardon du prêt à taux
zéro et je crois que d'autres de pas le
seul effectivement d'autres sénateurs
je pense notamment à claude jeannerot
nous demandent également de revenir sur
l'universalité de ce prêt à taux zéro
plus
je voulais vous demander
si vous avez regardé je pourrais vous le
communiquer bien évidemment le tableau
de ressources correspondant à ce
caractère universel et je voudrais vous
citer quelques chiffres
si je retrouve mon tableau correspondant
au niveau de ressources pour ce prêt à
taux zéro en question et son caractère
universel concernant le neuvième et le
dixième des cils pour vous donner les
chiffres suivants veine je crois sur
chambéry qui est en zone b1 en zone b1
la tranche 9 commence à 2400 euros par
mois de revenus produits neufs et pour
de l'ancien la tranche 9 commence à 2176
euros la tranche 10 fake et sans ces
aides est très très hauts revenus
commencent à 2008 124 euros à chambéry
en zone b1 est ce qu'on va véritablement
considérer que quelqu'un qui gagne 2000
euros par mois est trop riche trop riche
pour être aidés en matière d'accession à
la propriété
je ne crois pas les chiffres de la zone
à sont encore plus sont dans une
caricature encore plus importante en
zone à
à paris par exemple est-ce qu'on va
sincèrement considéré que dans l'ancien
en tranches 10 quelqu'un qui gagne 4000
euros par mois est trop riche pour être
aidé mais vous savez comme moi mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs qu'un couple
qui gagne 4000 euros par mois en
l'occurrence ce sera non pas ma personne
en l'occurrence pour un couple pardonnez
moi
le chiffre de la tranche 9 sera 4019
euros et la tranche 10 sera 5600 euros
cour de l'ancien est ce que vous pouvez
véritablement nous dire aujourd'hui
qu'un couple qui gagne 4000 euros par
mwh à 39 et 5000 euros par mois
tranche 10 à paris peut devenir
propriétaire seule avec ce niveau de
revenus mais la réponse est évidemment
non quelqu'un qui a une 4000 ou 5000
euros par mois à paris ne peut pas
devenir propriétaire autrement dit si
vous remettez en cause l'universalité
tels que vous suggérez savent trés
armand dire que les classes moyennes ne
pourront pas devenir propriétaire là
encore dès lors que nous réservons ce
produit aux primo accédants ce ne sont
pas les plus riches de nos compatriotes
qui accèderont à ce produit là puisque
les plus riches de nos compatriotes sont
d'ores et déjà propriétaire et je
voulais donc insisté j'ai été un peu
long sur ce sujet la pardonnez moi mais
a insisté sur fait sur ce point voilà
pour le début de cette semaine de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement au
sénat pendant une semaine le sénat va
s'intéresser à l'efficacité des
politiques publiques avec demain un
débat portant sur les prélèvements
obligatoires ou encore jeudi un débat
portant sur la politique de coopération
et de développement de la france
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire les journaux
de 19h et de 22 heures et toujours notre
site publicsenat.fr
très bonne soirée sur notre chaîne